when you're in New York it's bad [ __ ]
o'clock okay
that's like Reese Witherspoon bad [ __ ]
or clock that's reason that's right
lizzo called a Reese Witherspoon a bad
[ __ ] ahead of her big win at the 2022
Emmy Awards and the Emmy goes to
lizards
I'm feeling good as hell
as you should be lizzo the singer made
her Emmy's debut rocking this stunning
red tool gown and once inside she taught
host Keenan Thompson a thing or two
about time while giving a special shout
out to the Legally Blonde star when
you're in New York it's bad [ __ ]
o'clock okay
that's like Reese Witherspoon bad [ __ ]
o'clock that's reason yeah catch Reese's
face seems like she was honored by the
honor and after twerking up the stage
and presenting an award it wasn't long
before lizzo accepted one of her own and
the Emmy goes to
[Applause]
lizard
show lizzo's watch out for the big girls
one outstanding competition program for
its debut season ending RuPaul's drag
races years-long winning streak
I'm very emotional
and the the trophy is nice but my
emotion is for these people who are on
this stage with me
the stories that they shared
they're not that unique they just don't
get the platform
telling stories let's just tell more
stories
and lizzo also had this powerful message
to send to her younger self when I was a
little girl
all I wanted to see was me in the media
someone fat like me
black like me beautiful like me
if I could go back and tell little lizzo
something I'll be like you gonna see
that person but [ __ ] it's gonna have to
be you the singer dedicated the win to
her big girls the women from the show
who are now her dance troupe on tour one
year
one year one year
men we're filming this television show
that would change their lives forever
they are in the award-winning
superstars who are going on a world tour
Make some noise for my big girls juaniti
caught up with The Talented backup
dancers in March they shared just how
much lizzo changed their lives how would
you say she has changed the game for big
girl dancers age I'll start with you
um just by simply sharing her space and
her platform to uplift us because she
recognized the problem in the industry
that you know big girls wasn't getting
enough representation as far as dance
and anything honestly so she used her
platform to open the show and like let
me get easier as a chance and we brought
it for you and now the big girls and
lizzo have a lot to celebrate
foreign